>> I’M NOT.
I’M SORRY.
>> Sandra: NOW TO THE
LOUISIANA, THE STATE WITH MORE
THAN 18,000 POSITIVE CORONAVIRUS
CASES AND OVER 700 DEATHS.
LOUISIANA LAWMAKERS, HE WAS 54
YEARS OLD AND CASEY STEGALL IS
LIVE ON ALL OF THAT FROM
ARLINGTON, TEXAS.
>> SANDRA, GOOD MORNING.
THE LAWMAKER’S ON THAT YOU SPEAK
OF CONFIRMING THE INFORMATION
THAT SO MANY PEOPLE HAD A FEAR
TO COME UP THAT HE LOST HIS DAD
AFTER A BATTLE WITH CORONAVIRUS
YESTERDAY.
HE WAS HOSPITALIZED LAST WEEK
AND THEN WAS PUT ON A
VENTILATOR.
HE JUST TOOK OFFICE IN JANUARY
OF THIS YEAR TO REPRESENT
LOUISIANA HOUSE DISTRICT 54.
THE REGGIE BEGALA WAS NOT NEW TO
PUBLIC OFFICE HE PREVIOUSLY
SERVED AS AN ADMINISTRATOR AND
AUDITOR OF HIS LOCAL PARISH.
THIS NEWS COMING ON A DAY THAT
HEALTH OFFICIALS IN NEW ORLEANS
REPORTED A DECLINE IN THE NUMBER
OF DEATHS OVER AN 24-HOUR PERIOD
ACROSS THE STATE.
GOVERNMENT LEADERS HAVE BEEN
CALLING FOR MORE COVID-19 TESTS
TO BE BROUGHT TO THE REGION.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS STILL
RUNNING SUMMITS DRIVE THROUGH
TESTING SITES BUT MOST TESTING
NOW BEING DONE AT HOSPITALS,
DOCTORS OFFICES AND CLINICS.
ALTHOUGH, YOU CAN ADD MAJOR
NATIONAL PHARMACY CHAINS TO THE
LIST.
THEY ARE NOW ADDING REGISTERED
PHARMACISTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
TO ADMINISTER CORONAVIRUS TESTS
ONCE THEY ARE TRAINED.
A HANDFUL OF WALGREENS LOCATIONS
ALREADY OFFERING DRIVE THROUGH
TESTING SITES AND AT CBS,
WALMART AND OTHERS ARE EXPECTED
TO COME ON MINE SOON.
NOW IS NOT THE TIME TO START
IGNORING SOCIAL DISTANCING
GUIDELINES.
>> THERE IS LIGHT IN ALL THIS
DARKNESS.
AND WE ENCOURAGE THEM TO
CONTINUE TO COMPLY WITH ALL THE
ORDERS IN PLACE.
>> THE SAME MESSAGE IS ALSO
BEING CIRCULATED ACROSS TEXAS
AND OTHER STATES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HERE IN TEXAS.
199 DEATHS HAVE BEEN REPORTED
AND THAT’S VERY LOW CONSIDERING
THE SIZE AND POPULATION OF THE